[Music]
I just this weekend was at an event
called drawdown learn with Paul Hawken
based on his book drawdown and the work
that he and the group of scientists have
done in explaining what we need to do to
drawdown global warming and what's
remarkable is that it has become
practical in other words they have
proven that refrigeration and the
chemicals we use in refrigeration is the
number one Paul Hawkens talked a lot
about the language we use to describe
climate change and his principal point
was that we treated as an evil that we
should be afraid of the war against
climate change or the battle against
climate change and and he went through a
whole list of the kinds of expressions
we use it's clear when it comes to
climate change as it's been clear about
drunk driving and smoking and all the
other things that we want people not to
do scaring them does not work and the
more frightened they become and the more
helpless they feel or powerless they
feel the more they shut down what's
brilliant about drawdown is you don't
need to speak in frightening
generalities about climate change we're
all going to die and we have 10 years
and all that stuff all the stuff we
talked about you can say depending on
what someone's interested in that
educating young girls is actually I
forget it's number three or number eight
in their list of what would affect
climate change and and one of somebody
on Paul Hawkens team was also talking
about this you you can immediately get
into political value battles and and and
just dead ends when you talk about what
you use the words climate change if you
talk about a specific initiative and you
explain what it is and you talk to
people who have a vested interest in it
you know farmers have a vested interest
in aspects of climate change coastal
cities have a vested interest in certain
aspects of climate change when you can
make it real and when you can talk about
things that actually could be
accomplished you shift from vague and
and fearful to concrete and actionable
and that's what that's where we are now
we we know we know the kinds of programs
that will actually that will actually
make a difference what I hope the book
does is make it clear that leading
change and being able to act on the
things that matter to people is not
inaccessible it isn't it doesn't require
a special degree it doesn't require
superhuman power people always say I
can't draw a straight line it has
nothing to do with that you know to
become a designer I hope that people see
that it is possible to step up and that
all that's really needed is for someone
to decide to do it and and to start
where they are to look at the reality of
the things around them and to think
about who needs to be part of a
conversation and to start a conversation
Meg Wheatley talks about the fact that
all change begins with a conversation
between people and that's really how to
begin the process of social change as
well
[Music]